à bully-les-mines je n'ai pas oublié
cette médaille voyez qu'on m'a donnée
celle de notre dame de lorette
mais au nom de quoi toutes ces femmes et
ces hommes sont tombés des discours de
haine de la bêtise humaine d'un choix
fait à un moment par des dirigeants de
manière folle de dire nous valons mieux
que le voisin
alors allons le détruire mais l'on le
détruire avec la chair des autres
madame le pen et ses amis ils seront
réfugiés au château de montre tout mais
ce sont vous et vos enfants qui rompt la
faire la même guerre qui en a fait
tomber tente étant alors le cédant pas
cela alors ils ne passeront pas alors
moi je l'envoie alors que toutes celles
et ceux qui aujourd'hui ont décidé
d'être les somnambules du 21e siècle
autant nous nous sommes debout
nous sommes en marche et nous irons au
bout avec responsabilité mais je veux
autre chose avec vous pour mon pays mais
passa passa passa
[Applaudissements]